well hello how are you i'm good hello
how are you
i'm good i feel like i see you all the
time because
well you know you're a viral sensation
[Music]
it's just kind of been a blur like i
mean we posted that first one
and it was like oh it'd be cool if it
had 100 000 views or something and if it
helped
bring a little bit of attention to my
music and now i'm like
doing tick tocks with jimmy fallon it
feels a little bit like a dream
not gonna lie i'm still adapting to
um what is all happening i bet i bet
i mean we're obsessed with the videos
we're obsessed with your voice
and just sort of the creativity around
all of this
so what inspired you to take random
internet posts
and turn them into these songs i was
consuming a lot of tick-tock
and really enjoying the platform and so
yeah i just kind of had that thought
like how funny would it be to take
something
really stupid or really silly rather
like an argument on the internet
and then spend days like crafting a pop
record around it
do you feel any pressure making these
videos or do they still feel really fun
at this point
um they're still fun they're still a lot
of fun
but now there's this kind of thought of
like millions of people will potentially
see this idea like it yeah it's a weird
context change
but no it's still a lot of fun